well this one's funny let me read this
one so I found this on my friends of one
of my buddies site and he posted it and
I think I think she's serious this woman
well it is Jezebel she she let's see
adult men shouldn't skateboard adult men
shouldn't skateboard let's try that
again with the caveat adult men who are
amateurs shouldn't skateboard all right
so that see that's where I think it's
that's why it's true because she's
saying if you're an amateur and you're a
middle-aged man you shouldn't make a
word it's like there's an extra no I
mean that Tony Hawk well obviously this
guy's do you know he's skating
Tony Rama I mean this is baller aha yeah
that's that's Tony hook put an X over
the most famous pro skateboarder in the
world well she talks if I mean she she
says it right here she's talking about
it's right it's an extreme sporting
activity that should be reserved for
teenage stoners Tony Hawk women and
girls who can easily kick my say a hey
and appear regularly in coffee table
photography books about major American
cities members of blink-182 and meet cat
the fictional cartoon mascot for cheesy
blasters no one else should skateboard
see I don't understand why women it's
any age can can skateboard but men well
look Wow oh they're so so she goes on to
saying yeah no one else to do it and
those who do are likely adult man
amateurs who are also big dumb babies
and who wants to be a big big dumb baby
listen listen look III have no problem
calling out that these bullet points man
they're their own point well I have no
problem calling out fake woke nests yeah
are there like we need to totally Rhian
this series come on she's joking
this is nose look she says I've
maintained this perfect opinion for
years now and I'd like to help the rest
of the world see the light humming cheek
no I don't think so listen listen the
number one is there's no greater
injustice than being sideswiped by a
skateboarder now
that sounds real I I grew up skating in
New York City and we we push hard we go
fast and I'm holding on cars I'm cutting
through traffic
careful sorry yeah and I yeah I've run
into a few people I've seen people get
clutter I I mean the Broadway bomb is
thousands of skaters tearing down the
street and I've seen manhole people
shaking out it's it's it's scary thing
Broadway goes like straight down
Manhattan yeah like the whole island all
the way twenty miles or something I
think the entire run but the Broadway
bomb is eight point two miles and then
you you ride your board straight down
all the way down to the goal yeah yeah
but but look so this is this is totally
true though you know it's like and if
you don't know the the rules not the
rules but you know the the general
etiquette of a skate park you know and
you just climb we ran in or trying to
skate in the street and you hit somebody
and your big dude you could probably
hurt someone really bad that's true so
your official position is that -
literally thinks men shouldn't
skateboard unless they're pros position
doesn't even make sense I mean no I'm
dumb I'm not saying I agree with this at
all I mean I taught skateboarding and I
taught a 68 year old guy who had just
had back surgery how to skateboard and
this dude started skating to work all
right so I've I've proven I think you
know it can happen well here's here's
what I think right let's uh I actually
think I kind of feel like I'm reading
this now I kind of feel like she is
being a bit serious as why let's check
this out number two is much like the
first point adult man skateboarders take
up too much space
imagine men spreading but tripled when
arms are extended for balance that's
just unnecessary
it does seem over-the-top oh she gets
mean right right right it's real mean
human so but but look this comeback it's
it kind of feels like she might actually
have a negative opinion about adults
capable I think she doesn't like
skateboarding in general what is being
silly about it well number three it's
unknown it's unnatural like humans
weren't born with wheels for feet for a
reason nothing while they're bladers
dude yeah agree we weren't a dolt men
skateboarders are often childish this is
a game for children do you know the
origins of skateboarding it was invented
in the late 1940s early 1950s for kids
to have stuff to do post-world War two
they would stand in boxes with some
wheels and roll around
it's 2020 we have better games and
endless war now I think that's actually
wrong I think it was like simulating
surfing
but probably that's probably true it is
a sport which negates any bad-boy edge
skateboarding supposedly gives off edgy
sunny sunny Southern California branding
has fooled everyone for generations I
also blame sublime records which is
funny because they are also from
Southern California whatever reason
skateboarding has been treated like a
cool counterculture exercise when it's
really just sports jock nonsense you've
been tricked no we haven't
skateboarding is in the Olympics yeah
everybody's known for the past two
decades that it's a mainstream approved
like acceptable sport and you literally
have coaches teaching kids and the core
skaters have tried to resist this escape
flirting is not sexy
you knew this one was coming the
internet dubbed Adam Brody a scum bro in
the Afro mentioned pick for a reason
television and the Tony Hawk pro skater
soundtrack has of the public to believe
that skateboarding is sexy
are you a mindless corporate drone do
you enjoy getting spoon-fed your mundane
opinions skateboarding is only hot if
you're into effing men who haven't
matured past adolescence and I guess or
are a multi-millionaire Olympic gold
medalist
- oh yeah Nyjah suzhen killer skaters oh
that dude is like one of most powerful
people in the world from skateboarding
yeah yep his mansion is nuts you see
that he did us he did it I think he did
a YouTube thing where he like did a tour
of his house no I haven't seen it man
it's crazy I live in the suburbs of
Philly in it you know it's a nice house
but man I should I should have kept
skating what did I do
complained about Democrats you're good
to seven it's dangerous it's dangerous
peril lurks are on every corner already
why amp up the possibility of breaking a
bone I've broken one bone in 20 years of
skateboarding it was because someone
else hit me yeah yeah nah get out of
here yeah plus there are much cooler
ways to injure yourself for example you
know you know I think so silly
skateboarding has a lower injury right
than like football you know why you know
why well skateboarders train themselves
to fall like a part of it is knowing how
to be safe
yeah and that's true for our other
sports too but when you're playing like
football or basketball other people
could crash into you yeah exactly I'm
skateboarding it happens too that's how
I got injured a skateboarding and
someone hit my finger and it spun all
the way around and what is it what does
it call the metacarpal tarsal
carpal metacarpal metacarpal split like
I can still feel it someone else I was
stoned yeah I was mid frontside 360 on a
quarter pipe and I'm like flying in the
air my hand was out and he drops in not
paying attention hits my finger and one
and I was like it didn't hurt so much as
it was like weird I couldn't move my
hand anymore about this weird the
doctors were impressed though they're
like they're like your bones are
incredibly dense hi you must been hit by
a truck and I'm like stoner
and he told me I was lucky because the
split was very sharp and almost severed
the nerves in my hand oh man yeah and I
play guitar you know so I was died then
someone else hit me it's dangerous when
stoned people aren't paying attention so
when you play other sports where there's
like contact sports even mm-hmm yes
someone's gonna crash into you yeah that
was my first boner play yeah was playing
football second bow and I broke
skateboarding is actively embarrassing
I'm you know what you know what hold on
you know what it feels like some
skateboarder broke her heart right
seriously really it's like hold on
angry skater I'm not convinced she's
being serious I do think some of these
things are bordering on a little mean
yeah you know I really think it is
though what I think it's that these news
organizations need to current Washington
say news and news need to crank out
content non-stop yeah and so she's
probably sitting there like well and
someone get bored skate but mention
skateboard and I'll just write some song
look at that guy yeah like she like
Watts some middle-aged guy hit someone
else she's like that's it I got to write
an article about you know you know I
think it really is though I think it's
just like an attempt at like excuse me
shock humor you know yeah I think so I
don't have a problem with it I think
it's fine I've I've laughed so much on
this I'm like I don't want to accuse
someone of being serious for trying to
make jokes you know I mean I think I
don't know like some some of them kind
of feel real but it does feel like she's
being overly silly on purpose yeah but
it's kind of like I don't know what your
point is you know I mean like what's the
what's the what's the punchline
there there is no one that's just like
snark humor yeah I get it I get it you
know adult men skateboarders
the true enemy in skater boy you see
this is not serious a superficial
listener may read Avril Lavigne's opus
to be the product of a woman who has
internalized misogynistic culture and
they'd be right but the real enemy of
women is the skater boy for whom the
song is titled what do we know about him
he's a some man be a skateboarder see
bad next I like this is funny what what
wait what I'm actually kind of offended
by this because she's literally telling
women like yeah but come on it's kind of
midlife crisis Eve professionals are the
exception sure but why hold on to a
skateboard skateboarding simply because
you loved doing it as a clove smoking
class cutter being an adult is dope get
into adult stuff and if that means I do
not mean scourge of the skating world
the longboard which is the chosen
vehicle for like surfer II skaters that
is the worst like have you ever hiked go
for a damn hike I use the one damn
there's no I said twice oh well learn to
cook I've heard good things about
Allison Roman need I go on I'll answer
that one no adult men shouldn't
skateboard leave that to the ladies and
children disagree if you must but just
know that you are wrong III think she's
being funny you think she's serious
i yeah i do i think there's an essence
of seriousness in there I don't think
she's maybe every joke has truth but I
don't think she seriously cares I do
think it's kind of dumb it only I don't
think anybody clicked on there's so much
finger in there I'll tell you what man
I'm building a skate park in my backyard
so we take faux offence at your phone
ffensive article I think it's leave it
about yeah all right so let's hit the
last super chance I think we're gonna
wrap up so what do we got left on the
the old super chet supa Bam Bam says hey
Tim it did you hear about the how
lobbyists were trying to censor Louis
Rossman who was testifying about the
right to repair in Congress I didn't I
don't know what about that Alex Keith
says Tim will you ever collaborate with
Jimmy Dore I did
Jimmy's amazing I love Jimmy Dore and
he's like a he's a lefty you know he's
like very left to me and he's very much
Pro Bernie I'm not very Pro Bernie but I
think we agree on all the right all the
right things and that's why you know
like him and Rogan get along really well
Jimmy is awesome I'm a big fan the moral
gray I have a goal to become a
psychiatrist
mr. counselor to provide free or at
least affordable mental care to people
can hardly afford school any ideas nah
man sorry how our YouTube show yeah I
mean that's the easy answer but that's
the first thing I'm doing it the real
secret to success is perseverance so I
you know I people always want to do
YouTube and I'm like listen man you got
a you get you have to figure it out it's
not it's not like everybody's gonna do
it yeah maybe maybe you're a good I
don't know I don't know you know I I did
news so this was a natural evolution
what I was are what I was already doing
back for boot says I'm currently
concerned with the recent power creep in
magic gathering that has caused unfun
play at all levels do you think we can
help
okö from we can keep oka from happening
again there's always gonna be a no Co no
Banat and then the meta will adjust
that's just it's I have just I want to
make a new card game man I love magic
magic sorry oh and that power creep is
real I mean they're so well let's
display a lot of people might not know
basically as they try to adapt new sets
to make them fun and exciting they
increase the power of each card and so
eventually you get to a ridiculous set
where there's just in it's just
ridiculous like single turn wins and
like the game becomes less fun because I
went to nuts and they try to like do a
new set where they walk it all back and
then it's kind of boring yeah exactly
yeah so yeah you know we'll see what
happens but I think we're gonna we're
gonna give it a few more minutes just so
everybody can get them any last Super
chat so we'll go for maybe another like
810 and we'll just get some witty banter
in what we pretend we'll talk about
something but uh let's let's talk about
what we're gonna do with the skate park
out there you want to do a quarter pipe
- well we got a mini ramp
we got the mini ramp we've got if you if
you go do this go to Instagram - calm
/team cast great promo for my Instagram
and I put up a video showing we built
it's not really a rail we use its its
what is it it's a composite plastic deck
slats yeah 16 feet long to make a rail
I'm doing air quotes it's not like you
know photos aren't familiar with rail is
like a metal bar it's a flat square so
it functions kind of like a flat rail to
some degree and then we built what we
call a butter bench using composite
plastic deck slats on top of a wooden
box I built and you can sit on it or you
can grind on it which you jump up with
your skateboard and slide across it so
we're gonna seal the concrete that's my
that's you know I think we're not gonna
do it too heavily I talked with the the
dude who's doing the building so it's
not gonna be too slippery but it's gonna
be gonna be pretty good you know we're
gonna do some crazy stuff you know I
always wanted to do
I want a little sloppy bar or something
yeah yeah totally but here's my mission
I want to make the only way you can get
second floor is if you can carve up a
vert wall everybody else you can't come
up we're gonna have we're gonna have a
barrel full of pop-tarts we're gonna
have an arcade machine we're gonna have
you know a beer cooler and we're all
gonna be set up you're chilling but you
can't cover up that wall sorry man ten
foot now before you wrote but getting
down is your responsibility you guys you
got a drop down I'm serious about
wanting to do that the wall all the ways
want to do that no like instead of
stairs or a rope yes it's a wall it's a
vertical wall so like if those aren't
familiar if you've seen like the Ninja
Warrior where they have to run up the
curved wall oh yeah imagine that and so
look how many people don't make it I
can't believe how many people don't know
but we skate we skate I could run up a
15-foot vertical wall yeah just like a
clean well I'm used to it you like it's
really funny in skating like here
actually take a look at this this uh
Tony Hawk is in this bowl which looks
like it's probably what like maybe 10 12
feet deep yeah it's a pretty big bowl
it's pretty me and Tony Hawk's really
tall he's like six something so what
ends up happening is often in
skateboarding little kids will go into a
pool and they can't get out because you
got to run up the wall and jump out and
even ninja warriors fell with that yeah
so almost every skateboarder learns how
to easily run up these walls pull
themselves up yeah
if I did a 10 to 12-foot vert wall hmm
that led to a deck full of goodies and a
barbecue grill yeah
we have skateboards so we just skate
right up true basically what you do you
get goods you get a good speed that gets
you over the over the top and then
probably get to the top you shift your
weight forward the board pops up and you
catch it and you know most skateboarders
who've been skating long enough not to
do that and then we're gonna party you
have some burgers and some beers and
some pop-tarts and you can show on the
floor
you